de ruines au sens propre et figuré du
terme il s'agit d'un résultat désastreux
mais logique de deux décennies
d'imposition de leur modèle de
construction étatique de la part des
états unis et de l'otan le désir
persistant des occidentaux de remodeler
l'organisant sur leurs propres modèles
amener de tristes concernant l'hostilité
en interne et l'effusion de sang la
polarisation de la société un
effondrement socio-économique une
catastrophe humanitaire
cela favorise l essor des groupes
terroristes internationaux à la
production de drogues et de corruption
qui s'en soucie aux états unis ou dans
d'autres capitales occidentales
situé à des milliers de kilomètres
l'afghanistan a toujours été pour
seulement un outil pratique pour la
réalisation de leur projet géopolitique
mercantile désormais une nouvelle
administration et au pouvoir à kaboul
c'est la réalité objective
une possibilité réelle bien que
difficile à atteindre celle de revenir
sur la scène internationale en tant
qu'etat responsable et pacifique se
présente à sauver les objectifs énoncés
par les zones nouvelles par les
nouvelles autorités afghanes de
stabiliser la situation
politico-militaire
d'inclure dans le gouvernement
provisoire des représentants des
minorités nationales et des forces
politiques
d'organiser des élections régionales
général suscitent le respecte les
efforts pour reprendre les activités des
organes gouvernementaux créer une armée
régulière et assurer la sécurité des
missions diplomatiques étrangères sont à
noter
la russie n'a pas pour habitude
d'imposer ses conseils ses
recommandations à qui que ce soit c'est
à l'histoire elle même qui suggère c'est
l'histoire elle-même qui suggère des
solutions efficaces au premier
il est vital que les intérêts de toutes
les forces et nos politiques du pays
soient prises en compte et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous souhaitons
fermement et systématiquement la
création d'un gouvernement afghan
véritablement tous les citoyens doivent
savoir que leurs droits
et leurs aspirations légitimes doivent
s'appuyer non pas sur des paroles mais
sur les actes et qu'elles seront
protégés par la loi
dans le respect des traditions et
coutumes locales il est évident que sans
lutter délibérément contre la production
et le trafic de drogue ainsi que contre
les groupes touriste terroriste
international qui se sont opérés en
afghanistan et qu'ils sont manipulés de
l'extérieur il est peu probable que la
mise en place une politique étrangère
normale soit possible surtout vis-à-vis
des pays voisins qui sont avant tout
dans le collimateur de s'efforce d'être
destructives
de notre côté nous comptons avoir
recours à tous les instruments
internationaux et régionaux qui sont à
notre disposition
c'est à dire les ressources de l'onu de
l'eau et c'est de l'eau tsc et d'autres
structures multilatérale
nous notons avec satisfaction que les
positions des participants au récent
sommet à dushanbe douchanbé sont proches
nous sommes également satisfaits des
résultats de la réunion spéciale
conjointe entre les membres de l'hôtesse
et et de l'eau cs
démission à l'ordre du jour sont des
hommes et celle de l'arrêt du contrôle
des flux migratoires en provenance
d'afghanistan car sous couvert de
réfugiés des éléments terroristes et
criminels peuvent et tentent déjà de
pénétrer dans les pays voisins cet
objectif ne peut être atteint qu'en
créant des conditions de vie normales en
afghanistan à l'avenir cela sera une
condition importante pour le retour
progressif des afghans dans leur pays
une nouvelle fois j'appelle les pays
voisins à éviter toute présence
militaire sur leur territoire de la part
des états unis ou de l'otan qui ont
prévu d'installer
de transférer leurs fausses quêter en
afghanistan
donc il faut mettre en place un système
de santé d'enseignement
et des mesures d infrastructure efficace
dans le domaine social tout cela va
représenter des dépenses considérables
et je tiens souligné à cet égard
que tous les tous ceux qui ont mis le
pays dans cette a dans cet état
déplorable
devrait aujourd'hui se mobiliser pour
aider financièrement sur le plan
humanitaire les afghans
les principes de conférences organisées
simplement pour le plaisir de se réunir
en occident doivent maintenant
travailler concrètes sur cet effort
et l'organisation des nations unies a un
rôle ici important et les participants
du format moscou ce sont justement
adressée à l'onu le 20 octobre dernier
et la russie est prête à apporter sa
contribution à cette oeuvre et
prochainement nous a l'intention
d'adresser une aide humanitaire nos
partenaires afghans avec des produits de
première nécessité des médicaments et en
conclusion je voudrais à vous souhaiter
à tous un travail fructueux et je vous
remercie pour votre attention